[Applause]
is this good enough quality okay let's
let's start the match
[Applause]
oh what a great point that's how you do
it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we'll we'll put a table there after this
first game oh that's a good one the
serving
oh the edge the edge guy
okay first set 11:9 to auto to make
makeable good shots good placement and
that's the first point
whoa
nice backhand is this going to author
one - its water backhand that was a
great backhand
okay three seven good sushi but now
eight three it's good strawberry now
it's off the serving deal by the way
yeah it's it's super warm in this hall
it's play here
good shot good shot can he kill the
points yes he can
how did he touch did it touch okay the
umpire is giving point to what that
touched lucky lucky one really don't
know the second and there we go what
happened there Mick was leading a three
and then it went to eleven eight it's
actually not a white shirt that I was
wearing
it's a pink which I'll it just looks
like a white one from the video one one
okay sorry now they visible again
and playin a lot or a few more on a
basic level that's a good point again
send the hello to Brazil hello guys can
he now keep the hippest lead seven three
okay what now gonna happen some loving
the edge they load to the call timeout
[Music]
[Applause]
good serve Oh what's happening now board
game points the Chaika speared okay
second oh well that's the second game
point worn by me cousin one game stick
to my game leading from there good point
there's a great point
oh who do who do I think it's going to
win its win this one both are really
good players at this time oh that's
that's a story point who are you telling
that to to win four games and this is
current two games to one okay
it was three games to zero down five
four greetings from Hungary thank you
unfortunately that's a good one that's a
good great point look at this one look
at this one what a point Oh
Finland we used to play there Table
Tennis like a long time ago in there
then we actually met for every six
points after six points you can always
go to the towel for a short break six
seven
oh sorry point you may recover but no
six eight for Myka it's great to have
you guys commenting it's nine mica sown
serves to serves to come he went for a
big it goes let's see
and when it's a Kenton there is a serve
one serve what is 3 point I was so lucky
well good flip good recovery good
recovery
whoa deserving well 1324 that was the
first time that actually saw autumn
moving I seriously if you really want to
keep his beard such a big stake in this
match but not new service that's it
Lancers
great great point
and he misses the chop alone sir and
then kind of misses are kind of like
easy and he misses
16:14 - oughta just think mica is one
game away from getting a haircut
always the oh what a shot
[Applause]
what a shot
love you this much later this is the
match 6-4 unforced error once again set
on 4 for 9 free haircut I agree 8 who
had it come back playing with me he's
giving him some points not deserving
good what a comeback
can I finish it face that's a
million-dollar place yeah we're gonna
first match point to Otto
okay we'll see
Oh 11
once again
ride-alongs here oh he misses it Vika
what happened there four games to one
here we go then
there it goes there it goes it's
actually looking pretty good that's good
enough yeah we actually think like the
short hair like suits you quite well
this is all unnecessary here it's a bit
fine touch button oh no I can see my
reflection it's pretty good from widely
then he looks pretty nice a lot of hair
sorry this is my new style there is
there it was there was quite exciting
match though well played both of you
sorry for the there was a lot of
technical difficulties yeah yeah but at
least you you got to see yeah it live
yes pretty nice I think but yeah thanks
guys this was the 500k much okay okay
thanks guys